- [Narrator] In previous
videos we've talked at length
about fiscal policy and in other videos
we've talked at length
about monetary policy.
But now we're going to
talk about them together
because at any given time in a country
there is some type of
fiscal policy going on
and in parallel there might be
some type of monetary policy going on.
But first let's just remind
ourselves what fiscal policy is.
This would be government
changing the amount of taxes
or government spending.
So this is all about taxes and or
and or, government,
government spending.
And why would that matter?
Well if you change the amount of taxes
you would change the amount
of money that individuals
and or corporations might have
which might change aggregate demand.
Similarly, if the
government goes out there,
spends more or less, that also
would change aggregate demand
and this could be used as
a tool in order to attempt
to engineer what the economy's output is.
Now monetary policy on the other hand,
it's very important not
to, not to get confused
between these two.
This is all about central, central banks.
And I know a lot of you might be thinking,
hey isn't the central bank
part of the government?
And I would tell you, well it depends
what country you're in and depends
how you view part of the government.
In the United States for example,
the Federal Reserve System
is quasi-independent.
It is true that the
executive makes appointments
including the chairman of
the Federal Reserve Bank,
but it should be acting independently
from the federal government.
Now this is all about central
banks changing money supply,
so money supply,
to impact or to target
oftentimes, interest rates.
And now why would this matter
if we're thinking about
engineering, so to speak,
where we are relative to
full employment output?
Well with low interest
rates, borrowing is cheaper
so people might be willing
to borrow and spend more
or corporations might be willing
to borrow and invest more.
On the other hand if you
had higher interest rates
it would go the other way.
Either way you have an
impact on aggregate demand.
So with that primer out of the way,
let's look at two different
scenarios for an economy.
So in this first scenario,
let's call this scenario one,
pause the video and think
about where this economy
is operating relative to
full employment output.
Well you can see here that
our equilibrium level of
output, Y sub one, is below
our full employment output.
So here we have a negative output gap.
And so from the federal
government's point of view
they might wanna say, hey
let's do some expansionary
fiscal policy in order to shift
the aggregate demand curve
to the right.
Well what would be
expansionary fiscal policy?
Well you could lower taxes.
That could shift aggregate
demand to the right.
People would have more
money in their pockets.
Corporations might have
more money to spend with,
to invest with.
The other option is that
the government could just
directly spend more.
If it spends more that
also would have the impact
of shifting aggregate demand to the right.
But in parallel with the fiscal policy,
what might the monetary policy look like?
Well an expansionary
monetary policy would be to
increase the money supply.
Increase the money supply with the goal,
which would have the impact,
or usually would have the impact,
of lowering interest rates
which would make borrowing cheaper.
And so corporations might invest more
and people might borrow and spend more.
Either way, or especially
if both is happening,
you are going to shift
aggregate demand to the right.
So with this expansionary
fiscal and monetary policy
you might get to a situation like this.
Maybe aggregate demand gets shifted enough
so we get to a world like this.
So that's aggregate demand curve two.
We're now, our equilibrium
level of output,
we're at full employment output
and our price level has gone,
has gone up.
And generally speaking,
expansionary policy
whether we're talking about
expansionary fiscal policy
or expansionary monetary policy,
you're going to see the price level go up.
Now let's look at scenario two here.
What are we dealing with here?
Well as you can imagine
it's the opposite situation.
We have a positive output gap.
Our equilibrium level of output
is above our full employment output.
And so this is a situation
where the federal government
might say, hey our economy
is at risk from overheating.
That's typically not what they say.
They tend to like it 'cause
it's good for winning election.
But they might say, if it's
a prudent federal government,
they might say hey this
is the time to maybe
pay down some of the government debt.
Or be a little bit more
fiscally responsible.
And so what they might do is have
a contractionary fiscal policy.
So that would be taxes
might increase and or
government, government
spending might go down.
Neither of these things
tend to be very popular.
In general contractionary fiscal policy
is not a good way to win elections.
But a prudent government
might be willing to do this
and either of them,
because of the same reasons
we just talked about,
might have the effect of
shifting aggregate demand to the left.
Similarly, the Federal
Reserve might wanna do a
contractionary monetary policy.
And contractionary monetary
policy is far more common.
Where the Federal Reserve says, hey
when we are producing above
our full employment output
inflation might get out of control.
So what they might do is
lower the money supply,
money supply,
which would have the impact,
or usually would have the impact,
of increasing interest rates
making borrowing more expensive
so people might borrow and spend less
and corporations might invest less.
And so either way you
might have the effect
of shifting aggregate demand to the left.
So aggregate demand
might look like this now.
That's aggregate demand two.
Our equilibrium level of output now
is at full employment output.
And now our price level, our
price level, has gone down.
And generally speaking,
contractionary monetary policy
and or contractionary fiscal
policy will have the impact
of at least slowing down inflation.
I'll leave you there.
The big takeaway here is, fiscal
policy and monetary policy
seldom act in isolation.
Oftentimes when we're
at a negative output gap
you have expansionary
policies in both dimensions.
And in a positive output
gap it might be prudent
to have contractionary
policies in both dimensions.
Now one question you might ask is
what if they go in opposite directions?
What if, say, fiscal
policy is expansionary
while monetary policy is contractionary?
Well there it depends.
They might offset each other.
In fact, sometimes the
central bank might have
a contractionary policy because they think
that the federal government
is being too expansionary.
All interesting things to think about.